>> Neil: SOME IMPRESSIVE
COMPANY ON THAT ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE BILLIONAIRE COFOUNDER, 84
YEARS YOUNG, WHERE THE MASK!
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS IS SOMETHING WE CAN DEAL
WITH VERY EASILY, IT’S CALLED A
MASK.
IF YOU PUT A MASK ON, YOU ARE
ADDRESSING 90% OF THE CHANCE OF
GETTING AN INFECTED.
I DON’T UNDERSTAND, I KNOW I’M
84 AND I’M TERRIFIED ABOUT
GETTING IT.
WHENEVER I LEAVE MY HOME.
I’VE GOT A MASK TO PUT ON
BECAUSE I KNOW IT’S GOING TO
HELP.
>> Neil: I WANT TO GO TO THE
CONGRESSMAN, ONE OF THE MORE
HARDHEAD STATES WITH THESE
RECENT SPIKES.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE MASK
THING?
YOU HAVE THESE FOLKS SAYING,
WHERE IT, AT LEAST WE CAN HAVE
MORE CONTROL OVER CONTROLLING
THE SPIKES.
>> I HAVE TO TELL YOU I’M
RETICENT TO BELIEVE THAT IF A
MASK WORK SO WELL THEN WHY IS
L.A. SPIKING AND SURGING WITH
COVID CASES WHERE THEY’VE HAD A
MANDATORY MASK REGULATION IN
EFFECT FOR SEVEN WEEKS NOW.
THERE IS NO EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE
THAT THAT IS THE CASE.
THOSE WHO ARE DOCTORS AND THOSE
WHO ARE --
>> Neil: I THINK A LOT WERE
IGNORING IT.
TO BE CLEAR, MANY WERE IGNORING
THAT.
THESE STATES WERE TRYING TO PUSH
IT, PEOPLE WERE DOING IT.
>> I HAVE REBUKED THREE
LITERATURE REVIEWS THAT
HAVE REVIEWED OVER 90
STUDIES OF THE EFFICACY OF MASKS
THEY HAVE COME TO THE SAME
CONCLUSION, ONLY ONE MASK THAT
HAS ANY EFFICACY AND THAT’S THE
ENDN-95.IF PEOPLE WANT TO WEAR M
>> Neil: YOU DON’T THINK IT
HAS ANY BENEFIT AT ALL?
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE SAYING THE
ISSUE IS AND FOR PROTECTING THE
PERSON WHO’S WEARING IT, BUT THE
PERSON THEY’RE COMING IN CONTACT
WITH IN THE PROCESS.
I ONLY RAISE THIS BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU SEPARATELY CALL FOR ENDING
THE PRESIDENT’S CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE BECAUSE THEY’RE NOT
ECHOING THE PRESIDENT’S ECONOMIC
CONCERNS.
DO YOU THINK THAT’S RISKY?
>> NO, I DON’T.
I APPRECIATE WHAT THE
VICE PRESIDENT HAS DONE AND I
THINK HE IS DONE A GREAT JOB.
ONE OF THE THINGS I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT IS TO MAKE SURE THERE
IS PPE AND THAT TYPE OF THING
AVAILABLE TO MEDICAL CARE
WORKERS OR EVEN THE PUBLIC.
I’M OKAY WITH THAT.
I THINK WHEN DR. FAUCI HAS BEEN
ALL OVER THE BALLPARK, JUST A
COUPLE MONTHS AGO, YOU SHOULD
WEAR A MASK IF YOU’RE HEALTHY,
THEN WEARING A MASK AS A SYMBOL,
AND NOW EVERYBODY NEEDS TO WEAR
A MASK.
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN INCONSISTENT
WITH HIM AND NOW HE’S OPINING ON
THINGS LIKE, MAYBE THERE SHOULD
BE NO SPORTS IN OCTOBER.
>> Neil: FORGOT DR. FAUCI FOR
A SECOND.
YOU REPRESENT A STATE THAT HAS
THE MOST SERIOUS SPIKES IN
CASES.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF
CASES ON JUST THE PAST SEVEN
DAYS OR 100,000, ARIZONA RATES
NUMBER ONE AT 39.1, DAILY NEW
CASES.
FURTHERMORE THE SPIKE HAS PICKED
UP DOUBLE DIGITS TEAM IN THE
LAST TWO WEEKS.
YOU HAVE HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
ICU BED USE, THE HIGHEST OF THIS
CRISIS.
YOU ARE TELLING PEOPLE TO GET
RID OF IT?
PEOPLE ARE LISTENING TO YOU AND
YOUR SAYING WE CAN EASE UP!
>> NO, I’M SAYING YOU’RE TAKING
DATA POINTS AND YOUR CHERRY
PICKING THOSE DATA POINTS.
BECAUSE YOU CAN TAKE THE
HOSPITALIZATION --
>> Neil: I’M NOT CHERRY
PICKING ANYTHING!
I’M TELLING YOU ABOUT THE ICU,
I’M TELLING YOU ABOUT THE
HOSPITAL BED USES.
I’M NOT SAY THE WHOLE STATE, YOU
RIGHT NOW HAVE THE NATION’S
HIGHEST RATE.
>> IF YOU LET ME RESPOND I WILL
A FEW AT EVERY ONE OF THOSE DATA
POINTS.
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST NUMBER
PERHAPS ON A PER CAPITA BASIS OF
NEW CASES.
THOSE ARE MOSTLY COMING THE AGE
20-44 BRACKETS.
WE HAVE ALSO HAD OVER THE PAST
THREE WEEKS A REDUCTION IN
HOSPITALIZATIONS BY ALMOST 100%,
11.5, DOWN TO 5.6 TODAY.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
FATALITY RATES, WE HAVE MOVED
FROM OVER 4%, JUST ABOUT 30 DAYS
AGO NOW TO WRITE AT 2%.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT TRANSPIRE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE 5300 PEOPLE
THAT HAD BEEN DISCHARGED FROM
HOSPITALS IN THE LAST 30 DAYS
AND YOU LOOK AT THE LAST EIGHT
DAYS, WHAT YOU WOULD SEE IS
EVERY DAY WE’VE HAD AN INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF DISCHARGES.
WE HAVE ACTUALLY HAD A REDUCTION
IN THE LAST TWO DAYS IN THE ICU
BED USES.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THAT --
>> Neil: 86% OF THOSE BEDS ARE
BEING USED AT 89% OF GENERAL
HOSPITALS!
I’M NOT SAYING THEY’RE ALL
COVID-19 CASES, THAT USE IS THAT
A RECORD HIGH.
ALMOST SAYING YOU RECOMMENDING
THE PRESIDENT GET RID OF HIS
HEALTH CARE COMMISSION,
CORONAVIRUS COMMISSION BECAUSE
YOU DON’T LIKE WHAT EITHER
DR. BIRX IS SAYING OR DR. FAUCI
AS SAYING, THEY HAVE NO
POLITICAL AGENDA.
THERE WERE A DOCTORS AND THEY
THINK PEOPLE CAN GET CAVALIER.
I DON’T THINK THAT MEANS THERE
AND TIE THE PRESIDENT’S AGENDA.
THERE ARE PRO KEEPING AGENDA.
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHAT I THINK
HERE.
I THINK THAT THEY HAVE GONE WELL
PAST, THEY HAVE EXPIRED.
THEIR TIME OF USEFULNESS HAS
EXPIRED.
WHAT THEY DO IS WHEN THE
PRESIDENT COMES OUT AND MAKES A
POLICY, BECAUSE HE IS THE
PRESIDENT AND POLICYMAKER, WHEN
THEY MAKE THESE STATEMENTS, THEY
HAVE PANIC AND HYSTERIA AND
UNDERLINE WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
DOING.
THAT’S WHAT’S CRITICAL.
>> Neil: DOESN’T HE HAVE A
CONDITION BECAUSE HE DEFERS TO
THEM AS HEALTH EXPERTS?
THEY ARE CITING WORRIES AND THAT
WE CAN GET THIS UNDER CONTROL.
IT NEEDN’T BE A PANIC IF PEOPLE
SHOULD DO WHAT THEY’RE SUPPOSED
TO BE DOING.
ISN’T THAT WHAT DOCTORS DO, LOOK
AT PEOPLE’S LIVES?
>> DOCTORS DO WHO ARE TREATING
PEOPLE AND MEETING WITH THEM
DAILY AND I TALK TO THOSE
DOCTORS ON A REGULAR BASIS.
ONE IS THE LAST TIME DR. FAUCI
MET WITH AND TREATED A PATIENT
ON AN INDIVIDUAL BASIS?
WHEN YOU START TALKING TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE ON THE GROUND?
>> Neil: ONESIE LAST TIME YOU
HAVE?
>> I’M NOT A TRAINED PHYSICIAN.
WHAT I AM IS --
>> Neil: YOU’RE TELLING THE
ONES WHO ARE ON TO GET OFF THE
COMMISSION.
>> WHAT I’M SAYING IS, THE
TASK FORCE MAY NOT BE NECESSARY
ANYMORE AND WHAT I’M SAYING IS
DR. FAUCI AND DR. BIRX HAVE
UNDERMINED WHAT THIS PRESIDENT
IS TRYING TO DO.
>> Neil: IN THE MIDDLE OF
THESE UPTAKE IN CASES YOU THINK
IT’S A GOOD IDEA TO DISBAND THIS
COMMISSION NOW?
AND THE MIDDLE OF THIS?
I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
>> I THINK IT’S A GOOD IDEA BUT
FOR DIFFERENT REASONS.
IF YOU WOULD LET ME FINISH AND
TALK ABOUT THE ICU BED USAGE AND
WHY THE NUMBERS ARE IMPORTANT,
BUT THEY DON’T TELL THE FULL
PICTURE.
YOU NEED CONTACTS.
IF YOU LET ME TALK ABOUT THE
OVERALL BED USAGE IN ARIZONA --
>> Neil: I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
YOU BACK, I WILL GET YOU BACK,
90% BED USAGE IN THAT NECK OF
THE WOODS IS NOT A BIG DEAL WHEN
IT HAS DOUBLED IN THE LAST FEW
WEEKS.
>> I DIDN’T DOUBLE.
>> Neil: CONGRESSMAN, I WANT
TO THANK YOU.